[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
it's Timeless a House Targaryen Prince
of the City will now choose his first
opponent
s
House of the Dragon has proven itself a
worthy sibling series to HBO fantasy
Juggernaut Game of Thrones the new
series a prequel to The massively
popular show based on the writings of
celebrated Author George R.R Martin
swooped in and landed with the heft of
one of its wing stars and season one is
now certified fresh by comparison seven
of eight Game of Thrones seasons are
certified fresh with scores ranging from
55 on the final season to 97 percent on
season four
okay
what do you know about the circle I'm
told for Kristen is common-born son of
Lord dondarian Stuart but other than
that and the fact that he's just
unhorsed both of the Baratheon lights
I really couldn't see
season one of House of the Dragon first
introduced viewers to Young princess
renira Targaryen and her childhood
companion Allison Hightower and then
quickly aged them up to become adult
competitors in their own Game of Thrones
Emma Darcy took over as raniera and
Olivia Cook as Allison while Matt Smith
plays Prince Damon Targaryen Patty
considine was King viserys Targaryen Eve
Bess is Princess renice Targaryen and
Steve Toussaint plays Lord Corliss
Valerian the sea snake and just so you
don't get burnt by the fire of House
Targaryen this is your official spoiler
warning for House of the Dragon season
one
foreign
[Music]
so prepare yourselves as we find out
which episodes were most favored by
critics compared to those that were only
slightly less favored to be honest as we
count down the best house of the Dragon
episodes ranked by Tomato Meter
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
episode 3 second of his name Damon and
the sea snake battle the crab feeder the
realm celebrates aegon's second name day
and rainera faces the prospect of
marriage starring Patty considine Matt
Smith Reese of Fonz and directed by
Claire Kilner Gita Patel and Greg
yatanis critics say after viewers
acclimate to the jarring time skip
second of his name quickly Finds Its
stride with a focus on infernal
politicking rousing spectacle and some
rather nasty crabs
[Music]
thank you
knock
foreign
[Music]
number nine episode 9 the green Council
tensions begin to rise in the Royal
Court as the new coronation draws near
while Allison enlist Cole and aemon to
track down aegon
Otto gathers the great houses of
Westeros to affirm their allegiance
starring Emma Darcy Steve Toussaint
Olivia Cook and directed by Claire
Kilner Gita Patel and Greg yatanis
critics say beginning with
conspiratorial Whispers and ending with
a roaring declaration of war the green
council is a discomfortingly suspenseful
kickoff to the long-awaited dance of
dragons
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
not going
[Music]
number eight episode five we light the
way Damon visits his wife in the mail
the series and raniera broke her
agreements with the valerians and
Allison seeks the truth about the
princess starring Patty considine Matt
Smith Steve Toussaint and directed by
Claire Kilner Gita Patel and Greg
yatanis critics say holding true to the
westerosi rule that no wedding goes
according to plan we light the way is a
disturbing midpoint for House of the
Dragon punctuated by Shocking brutality
and queen Allison coming into her own
foreign
[Music]
do you know what color it glows when Old
Town calls its Banners To War
green
[Music]
congratulations
a blessing this is for you
please be seated
number seven episode two the Rogue
Prince renera oversteps at the small
Council the series is urged to secure
the succession through marriage and
Damon announces his intentions starring
Patty considine Millie Alcock Matt Smith
and directed by Claire Kilner Gita Patel
and Greg yatanis critics say stolen
dragon eggs and awkward matchmaking add
up to an installment that is designed to
lay foundations rather than Dazzle in
its own right but the Rogue Prince
succeeds in nesting juicy conflicts
foreign
all of you
see the [ __ ] Steel
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
number six episode one The Heirs of the
Dragon the series hosts a tournament to
celebrate the birth of his second child
renera welcomes her Uncle Damon back to
the red key starring Millie Alcock e
vest Matt Smith and directed by Claire
Kilner Gita Patel and Greg yatanis
critics say bearing the weight of a
hallowed TV lineage the errors of the
Dragon won't fully fire viewers up for
another Game of Thrones but solidly sets
the board with plenty of blood
foreign
starving and undisciplined
now
you're a pack of hounds
sated and toned for the hunt
city has fallen into squalor
crime of every breed has been allowed to
thrive
no longer
beginning tonight King's Landing will
learn to fear the color gold
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
my God
number five episode six the princess and
the queen Ten Years Later rainera
navigates Allison's continued
speculation about her children while
Damon and Lena weigh an offer in pentos
starring Olivia Cook Emma Darcy Fabian
Frankel and directed by Claire Kilner
Gita Patel and Greg yatanis critics say
while the longest time skip yet
diminishes some of this installment's
most shocking moments the commanding
introductions of Emma Darcy and Olivia
Cook make clear that the princess and
the queen will remain compulsively
watchable combatants
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Siri
police
can I say it
the record is Vermax
number four episode four king of the
narrow sea after rainera Cuts short her
tour of Westeros Damon introduces the
princess to the street of silk after
dark starring Millie Alcock Matt Smith
Sonia Mizuno and directed by Claire
Kilner Gita Patel and Greg etanus
critics say making for deeply
uncomfortable family viewing King of the
narrow sea trades dragonflame for
Dangerous Liaisons and goes a long way
towards deepening House of the dragon's
web of intrigue
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
number three episode eight the lord of
the tides with the drift Mark succession
suddenly critical Rainer tries to strike
a bargain with renice starring Patty
considine Emma Darcy Olivia Cook and
directed by Claire Kilner Gita Patel and
Greg yatanis critics say the family
comes together for a short-lived truce
in The Lord of the tides a mournful
installment that spotlights Patty
considine's moving performance as the
ailing King viserys
hmm
[Music]
final tribute
to the health of my nephews
Jace
Luke
and Joffrey
each of them handsome wise
strong payment come
let us drain our cups
to these three
strong boys I tell you to say that again
why
it was only a compliment
do you not think Yourself Strong
I was merely expressing how proud I am
of my family mother oh it seems my
nephews aren't quite as proud of theirs
thing
goes your quarters all of you go now
number two episode 10 The Black Queen
while mourning a tragic loss raniera
tries to hold the realm together and
Damon prepares for war starring Emma
Darcy Matt Smith Steve Tucson and
directed by Claire Kilner Gita Patel and
Greg yatanis critics say culminating in
a spectacular and tragic dance of
dragons amidst a storm the black queen
is a visually Splendid Capper to House
of the Dragons inaugural season
is the promise of War excite you you
cannot bend the knee to the high Towers
they stole your Birthright if you could
take the Iron Throne without putting
Otto hightower's head on a spike would
you are you not angry well I should
declare war because I'm angry no because
it's your duty as Queen to crush
Rebellion you know my oath reaches
beyond our personal ambitions
what
becoming war against the darkness in the
north a conqueror's dream
Sarah shared it with me when he named to
meet her
my brother was a slave to his omen's
importance
anything to make his feckless
as kings
dragon's dead
[Music]
laughs
I never told you
and finally number one episode seven
driftmark as the families gather on
driftmark for a funeral the series calls
for an end-to-end fighting and Allison
demands Justice starring Patty considine
Emma Darcy Olivia Cook and directed by
Claire Kilner Gita Patel and Greg etanus
critics say while the copious say for
night cinematography will prompt viewers
to adjust their brightness settings
driftmark is in exceedingly satisfying
Excursion into family spats and taboo
reunions
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
[Music]